dans un boisé, on veut protéger,
exemple très concret, Mathieu
Prost.
- Le gseseng à cinq folioles
a fait la fortune d'exportateurs
au 18e siecle, au point
de presque disparaître
à l'état sauvage, mais on trouve
cette espèce menacée ici.
MARILOU ALARIE
vice-présidente, Nature Québec
- On n'a pas besoin d'être
biologiste pour comprendre
qu'on est dans un milieu
extraordinaire.
- No s sommes sur le flanc sud
du mont Saint-Bruno,
à une vingtaine de kilomètres
de Montréal. Le boisé
des Hirondelles, qui couvre
six hectares, appartient
depuis 2006 au sénateur
Paul Massicotte, qui voulait
y construire une vingt
de maisons.
- Le ginseng à cinq folioles
a toujours été protégé, même
avant que le promoteur en fasse
l'acquisition, là, de la forêt
des Hirondelles. Ce qui a été
modifié, c'est au niveau de
la réglementation municipale :
alors la Ville a adopté en 2018
une réglementation qui encadre
la coupe d'arbres dans
ses milieux naturels d'intérêt.
- Ce qui vaut à la Ville d'être
poursuivie en cour supérieure
pour expropriation déguisée.
Le nouveau maire veut protéger
la petite forêt.
LUDOVIC GRISÉ FARAND, maire
de Saint-Bruno-de-Montarville
- Mais c'était le "free for
all" ici, là! Ça construisait
dans les boisés, ça construisait
n'importe comment! On a, il y a
deux mois, tenté de négocier
avec le propriétaire, donc
Sommet Prestige, afin d'acquérir
le boisé des Hirondelles.
Malheureusement, on n'a pas pu
s'entendre et sur quatre boisés
qu'on a tenté d'acquérir
dans la dernière année, c'est
le seul propriétaire avec lequel
on n'a pas pu s'entendre.
- En marge de la COP15, ponctuée
de manifestations, Tanya Handa
anime un colloque sur
la biodiversité. Cette voisine
du boisé des Hirondelles est
aussi professeure de biologie.
IRA TANYA HANDA,sssssssseure,
sciences biologiques, UQAM
- C'est un dossier très
important parce qu'on se
retrouve dans le sud du Québec,
où on a un grand déficit
d'aires protégées.
J'aimerais que justement
la science soit écoutée.- - - -e
printemps sera également étudié
de très près par cet avocat.
Me MARC BISHAI, avocat, Centre
du droit de l'environnement
- Si jamais la décision
du tribunal est que
la réglementation de
la municipalité est invalide,
se pose la question
de l'indemnisation. Et là,
on peut se poser la question :
à quel point est-ce que
ça appartient àcicicicicipalité
ou au gouvernement provincial
d'indemniser puisque le vrai
feu rouge dans le dossier pour
le promoteur, c'est, à notre
avis, maintenant la question
justement de la protection
des espèces. On ne peut plus,
comme ça a déjà été le cas dans
le passé, déplacer les individus
d'une espèce pour venir
détruire son milieu d'origine.
- Un milieu qui est
en attendant la décision
du tribunal.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Saint-Bruno-
de-Montarvill